foreign
[Music]
I am Japanese and I'm very glad to have
opportunity to speak here at the
Stafford today
so to be honest with you I am not so
good at listening to others my wife
always complains me that I don't listen
to her and my parents always told me
that hey how many times do I have to say
same thing to you when I grew up maybe
same as you
but on the other hand my wife is very
kind
she always asks me my opinion
so for example when we go for a drive on
weekends she always asks me what do I
want to eat for lunch
so one weekend
we went to a drive she asked me hey what
do you want to eat for lunch today
I said well today maybe some Texas
barbecue
she said oh that's a good idea but let's
go to Thai food today
actually I couldn't go with my friend
last week
so I said oh okay let's go Thai food
today
but next weekend we went for drive again
and she asked me same question
what do you want to eat for lunch today
so I said well today maybe something
spicy so how about Korean food today
she said oh sounds good so let's go to
Indian Cuisine today
actually it's spicy too
so I was like oh okay all right Curry
two
but
after several times of this conversation
I learned one thing that this is not the
time for me to tell what I want to eat
but actually this is a quiz to guess
what she wants to eat right
I think people who are laughing now had
similar experience before
but by the way it sounds like I start
complaining my wife but I do love my
wife and I do have my two kids and
appreciate them to allow me to come here
and share this topic so thank you Kana
Nick May
but my point here is that rubbery or
mankind is not so good at listening to
others
and what happened here was that she was
asking my opinion on her a side
but at the same time she was thinking
her own idea on her B-side
so whatever my response was she already
had the answer in her mind
and from that following week I started
guessing what she wants to eat and I
start putting my own voice into my
pocket
and exactly same thing is happening in
our business field
so I think many of you guys have taken a
course of design thinking of Stanford
and you may remember that the first step
of design thinking is reaching out the
end users or the workers at the very
front line and then ask their Viewpoint
without your hypothesis
but I think this without your hypothesis
is the most difficult point and most
important point for problem solving
in many cases when we ask their
Viewpoint at the same time we are
referring to our own past experience and
try to distort their true voice into our
own framework and try to create our own
convenient problem-solving story which
doesn't work very well
and what this was is that if we do this
again and again your users members or
clients start to guess what we expect
them to say and they start hiding their
true voice into their pocket
so at that moment it becomes very
difficult to reach their true voice so
that it becomes very difficult to
identify the loot rules of the problem
and then if you are in a higher position
or if you have great confidence of your
experience you should be careful about
that
because those hierarchical relationship
prevent you from missing others straight
away
and also for the startup companies that
are just beginning together members need
to be cautious about that
so in my case I'm currently working for
a new joint major project in the U.S so
some members are coming from two parent
companies and some members are coming
from different oems and some members are
coming from totally different background
and working as one team
but what often happened here was that on
a side everybody believes that oh we are
talking on the same topic so that we are
on the same page
but at the same time each one of us were
referring to our own past experience
which were totally different and then
the discussion was not so mesh
so in this case even if we could reach
some conclusion
the execution phase was not so effective
so
how can we stop this b side completely
my conclusion so far is it's impossible
but at least if we recognize that we are
not so good at listening to others and
respect the end users or the workers at
the very front line we call Gamba in
Japanese
we can control our b side a little bit
better and we can listen to
our sorry others voice as it is
so my message today is let's recognize
our b side and please ask your partner
what do you want to eat for lunch
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]